je m'appelle Thomas
je vis à Dijon
j'ai 36 ans
ambulancier c'est mon métier
[Musique]
c'est un métier qui reste assez varié
parce qu'on fait des sorties d'urgence
des sorties de l'hospitalisation on
côtoie tout le personnel de santé c'est
un métier médical mais social on a des
patients qu'on fait presque tous les
jours donc il y a une relation qui se
crée
l'ambulance n'y passe 10 à 12 heures par
jour pendant 4 jours c'est vraiment
notre titoi c'est notre bureau en fait
donc c'est pour ça que une ambulance en
fait quand on la prend le matin
normalement elle doit être parfaite tout
est pensé pour que le patiente le mieux
possible d'accord pas de souci
on part au CHS la Chartreuse
c'est une personne qui est à priori
schizophrénique et qui se serait
luxer l'épaule comme suspicion de
luxation d'épaule ou fracture on va voir
sur place
[Musique]
on a le petit goût d'adrénaline voilà
pour aller sur l'intervention et
on est beaucoup à la recherche de ça
l'adrénaline c'est ce qui fait que qu'on
aime ce métier aussi quoi
c'est là
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui est schizophrène on
le connaît pas on veut pas prendre de
risques nous donc on va y aller tout
doucement on va garder une certaine
distance et s'approcher de lui petit à
petit et voir s'il est coopératifs avec
nous
[Musique]
oui on va y aller là on attend en bas du
coup l'infirmière qui est avec les
papiers et puis on y va d'accord ils
sont comment là
la douleur on en est où ça va mieux
même dans un transport normal on rassure
les gens parce que on amène aux urgences
mais faut pas oublier qu'on amène aussi
des personnes
qui vont en chimio qui qui font des
dialyses qui font voilà on prend la
température avec les gens on arrive même
à déconner avec eux pour les rassurer
ça va ça a été
[Musique]
au 9e étage il demande les secours on ne
sait pas s'il y a une notion de chute
[Musique]
d'avoir l'oeil partout surtout
aujourd'hui entre les trottinettes les
vélos qui prennent les voies de bus les
trottoirs c'est ça reste très très
compliqué
tu le vois le 13
[Musique]
c'est pas possible a priori ce sera au
on nous avait dit au 13 c'est pas au 13
c'est au 12 on nous a dit 19e étage en
fait on remarque que le monsieur c'est
au 8e
ouais bonjour monsieur
fait mal
vous avez pas de douleur
vous êtes tombé comment est-ce que vous
pouvez bouger les jambes
ouvrez les yeux ouvrez les yeux
on fait un bilan médical donc avec
Monsieur c'est un plan en euros on fait
ça avec des questions qui sont toutes
simples qui est le président de la
République quel jour on est on va vite
appeler le 15 vite passer le bilan et
l'emmener aux urgences et voir avec
quels moyens on va le descendre en fait
jusqu'à l'ambulance
[Musique]
si je devais recommencer oui je referai
le même métier c'est un métier qui est
très enrichissant on apprend le médical
mais avant tout ce qui est social on
rencontre malheureusement toute la
misère du monde mais on veut être là
pour ces gens-là et c'est ce qui fait
que notre métier nous plaît j'espère que
j'aurai toujours cette
c'est adrénaline c'est fou de venir au
boulot et ne pas venir un jour avec la
boule au ventre
[Musique]